BRET?
>> Bret: JOHN, THANK YOU.
THE DEMOCRATS LOOKING TO
CHALLENGE PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
2020 ARE CALLING FOR THE
FULL RELEASE OF THE REPORT
BUT SOME ARE ALREADY
POINTING OUT THAT THE
ELECTION WILL BE MORE ABOUT
DIFFERENT ISSUES THAN THE
NOW COMPLETED INVESTIGATION.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY
TAKES A LOOK AT THE
CANDIDATES' STRATEGIES GOING
FORWARD.
>> BETO ISN'T READY TO LET
GO.
>> DO YOU THINK IT'S TIME
FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO -- THE
DEMOCRATIC CHALLENGERS TO
PUT THIS BEHIND THEM?
THERE IS A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS SUGGESTING.
>> TO PUT WHAT?
>> THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION?
>> NO.
>> BUT OTHER DEMOCRATS ARE
WARNING THAT IT WILL BE
TOUGH TO WIN NEXT YEAR IF
CANDIDATES KEEP CLINGING TO
COLLUSION.
>> IN 2018 THE ELECTION WAS
ABOUT REPUBLICANS NOT
KICKING PEOPLE OFF OF THEIR
HEALTH INSURANCE FOR
PRE-EXISTING CONDITION.
2020 IS GOING TO BE VERY
FOCUSED ON ECONOMIC ISSUES,
SO, GUESS WHAT?
WE CAN DO TWO THINGS AT
ONCE.
ENSURE THE LAW IS FOLLOWED
AND MAKE SURE WE ARE
FOCUSING ON IT OPTIMISTIC,
ECONOMIC AGENDA.
>> THE SURGEONING SOUTH BEND
MAYOR PETE BUTTIGIEG AGREES
DEMOCRATS STAND A BETTER
CHANCE STANDING ON POLICIES
NOT PROBES.
>> THIS IS FURTHER EVIDENCE
FOR DEMOCRATS TO THINK THIS
IS A WAY FOR THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY TO END IS BY WAY
OF INVESTIGATION.
THAT COULD, OF COURSE,
HAPPEN.
BUT WE HAVE GOT TO BE PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE KINDS OF
CONDITIONS THAT MADE IT
POSSIBLE FOR SOMEBODY LIKE
HIM TO GET HERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
>> CANDIDATES STILL HAVEN'T
SEEN MUELLER'S REPORT, BUT
THEY ARE DISSATISFIED WITH
THE ABRIDGED VERSION FROM
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
STACEY ABRAMS STILL
CONSIDERING A 2020 BID SET,
QUOTE:  I TEND TO THINK IT'S
KIND OF LIKE HAVING YOUR
BROTHER SUMMARIZE YOUR
REPORT CARD TO YOUR PARENTS.
CORY BOOKER BELIEVES THAT,
QUOTE:  THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
DESERVES THE FULL REPORT AND
FINDS FROM THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION IMMEDIATELY.
NOT JUST THE IN-HOUSE
SUMMARY FROM A TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL AND
ELIZABETH WARREN TWEETED:
CONGRESS VOTED 420 TO 0 TO
RELEASE THE FULL MUELLER
REPORT, NOT A SUMMARY FROM
HIS HAND PICKED ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
A.G. BARR, MAKE THE FULL
REPORT PUBLIC IMMEDIATELY.
THE SWELLS GATHERED TO SEE
BERNIE SANDERS IN CALIFORNIA
THIS WEEKEND ERUPTED IN
CHEERS AT THE MERE MENTION
OF AN UNREDANTED MUELLER
REPORT.
>> I DON'T WANT A SUMMARY OF
THE REPORT.
[CHEERS]
I WANT THE WHOLE DAMN
REPORT.
[CHEERS]
>> THE FRONTRUNNER IS BEHIND
THE REST OF THE PACK THOUGH
BECAUSE WE STILL DON'T KNOW
WHAT POTENTIAL CANDIDATE JOE
BIDEN MAKES OF MUELLER'S
FINDINGS.
THAT COULD CHANGE TOMORROW.
BIDEN HAS AN EVENT IN NEW
YORK.